I think the next venom movie will
reverse this classic origin by having
the Venom symbiote detached from Eddie
Brock reattached to Peter Parker who's
mad at Eddie and then he becomes the
black-suited spider-man maximum carnage
storyline on the big screen where the
kids have one essence the 90s I'm back I
did it I came back I survived
coronavirus funny put some heat on that
don't put ice preheat on that guy's this
is rogue theory this episode we're gonna
find out how spider-man is gone finally
meet venom but with us to find that out
well I'm Phillip Malina but who cares is
of course Erik Bosse hi I'm tingling too
Tommy but in a different place
[Laughter]
Tommy Bechtold is back I love you blow
out the other arm
[Laughter]
hello how is everyone hug as good and
you gave me the princess way just close
me out guys also in this episode we're
gonna be talking about kind of the only
recent Star Wars news
other than Leslie headland the cruiser
creator of a Russian doll is doing her
own exciting Disney Plus show now we've
also found out that Tyco is getting a
movie and we're gonna get into that
later but first much more important Sam
how you been I mean okay how are you
guys doing great Sam we don't have time
for this we gotta get it okay cool okay
so this week for the second time Tom
Hardy posted on his Instagram he's so
weird
yeah a picture of venom eating
spider-man and it's a thing he keeps
doing hi and it like and then he
immediately deletes it like almost like
ooh did he get in trouble for posting
that because it was too real or too hot
but Sony has been asked to respond to
these each time and they're just like no
we're not saying anything about it we're
not saying it means anything bro so not
not saying that spider-man's not not
gonna be in venom
so you see you catch my drift Tommy your
nose is bleeding so the rumor is this
serious that it's looking like
spider-man is definitely gonna have a
cameo in venom too
I want to know how to spider-man show up
in venom - let there be carnage let
there be rogue theories okay I have a
theory the thing is is it's kind of been
weird so far in the Sony verse that we
have a venom without a spider-man
because we know in the comics venom only
exists because Peter Parker had the
symbiote on him first it dripped off of
him onto his rival at the Daily Bugle
Eddie Brock and that's why venom has
spider-man qualities that's why he kind
of looks like spider-man why he has like
the spider esque logo yeah so it's just
kind of weird that they skip that step
in the first venom movie well I think
this next venom sequel will fix that I
think the next venom movie will reverse
this classic origin by having the Venom
symbiote detached from Eddie Brock
reattach to Peter Parker who's mad at
Eddie and then he becomes the black suit
at spider-man
that's fascinating but real quick why he
mad at Eddie well okay well so the last
time we saw Peter Parker was at the end
of spider-man part from home when j
jonah Jameson outed him to the world
right so I have to imagine the next time
we see Peter Parker in a movie he's
going to have to have left his
spider-man identity behind and what is
the thing he's most passionate about
well traditionally in the comics Peter
Parker works for feast it's a it's a
homeless care organization and I think
this is going to be
the chapter where we see him working
with homelessness outreach and I think
just to get away from the New York scene
he's gonna go to the West Coast and work
with the homeless people in San
Francisco which has a very very bad
homeless homelessness problem so I think
he's gonna be working for feast in San
Francisco but Jay jonah Jameson's
Network tracks him down and says oh this
is where Peter Parker is now he's gonna
reach out to local San Francisco
reporter Eddie Brock and it's gonna give
them an assignment says see if you can
do a story on this kid I'll pay top
dollar for any Peter Parker footage you
find and then so Eddie brought tracks
and down Peters like I'm done with that
I don't want to do I don't want to do
the media spotlight anymore but at he's
like look I promise it'll be a story
focused on homelessness plight in San
Francisco this what I care about so
Peter Parker reluctantly agrees but the
footage goes to change in Jameson they
chop it up to make it all about Peter
Parker it blows up Peter burger space he
gets fired from feast he's curious with
Eddie Brock and begins stalking him
right around the same time carnage
because remember carnage is in this
movie - let there be carnage he has
broken out of San Quentin wreaking havoc
all across San Francisco so Eddie Brock
has distracted while Peter Parker is
fighting them there's a battle that
leaves Eddie and venom wounded Peter
Parker goes up to him and the Venom
symbiote reattaches on to Peter Parker
to create the the black incarnation of
Peter Parker so basically this movie is
that he Brock fighting a war on two
fronts on one side carnage on the other
side this is this kid who we
accidentally betrayed Peter Parker and
he has to convince Peter Parker to side
with him and joining him in this fight
against carnage and the only way Peter
Parker agrees to do that is carnage
begins to target the homeless population
of San Francisco to create his drones
that's what's on the absolute carnage
storyline so Peter Parker oh my god
Eddie Brock join forces droning homeless
people oh god it's really freaked up how
many drafts into the script are you Oh
couple rewrites but a Sony isn't getting
back to me for whatever reason maybe
they already had people writing it I
guess whatever things are backed up
because of this whole lockdown I get it
yeah did you shove it in your
PlayStation yeah I it's one
many things are shoved into my
playstation there's PlayStation code for
something err I'm referring to my memory
cards remember you had to plug those
things in and it had like you could save
like 80 memories yeah you'll never
forget Eric that was so much that you
get automatically to Rogi oh just for
taking care of saying so much in the
episode that I don't - for you also for
you know what I'm gonna be generous this
time cuz also you've been looking out
for me hosting oh yeah for that so it's
three Rogi Wow Wow okay on my end
the Rogue is turned into some Sony brand
headphones see I already buy your
headphones when you write your movies
also a sign of the times it turned into
a nice cough drop hopefully I won't need
that right and also to keep us occupied
but also keep us aware the board game
pandemic hoho it's it's a fun game to
start playing but not a fun game to
think about in context of the real world
I have a feeling that Eric had a couple
of props ready for his roadies this week
Oh
Darrien so now get ready to get a lot of
roadies Eric because I want to see
everything you can okay where comes out
as just like hey two socks all right
who's next who's the brave soul that
wants to follow that entire epic film
alright I will go next and because I
believe brevity is the soul of wit I
will make mine more concise and better
so what are the digs do you have
directly at Eric that was me that was me
just covering up for the fact that mine
is only gonna be two minutes long anyway
digging into the life Foundation which
is the early evil organization that was
basically responsible for killing his
son John so that's gonna start becoming
like daily bugle and whatever his TMZ
show is in the spider SONA universe now
they're gonna be doing a lot of like
reporting on the
life foundation and it's gonna be clear
that it's become an obsession of his now
Peter Parker has at this point gone away
from his life as a spider-man and he is
now pursuing a career in journalism he's
going to school he attends a journalism
convention where he meets Eddie Brock
and he Brock then Hughes Peter Parker
into just the specific evils of the Life
Foundation the experimenting on
prisoners the the-the-the experimenting
on staff the experimenting on the
homeless experimenting on everyone Peter
then formulates in his brain an idea
that he will go to Jaejoong Jameson and
make a compromise with him that he will
take down the life foundation if J jonah
Jameson promises to stop going after
spider-man at all of his news outlets so
basically it's like a truce I'll go take
care of this problem you stop creating
problems for me no that's all fine and
good until they get there and they
realize that cleanness Cassidy is one of
those inmates that's been experimented
on and he now has become carnage and
that's where we get the team-up of I
don't believe that there's gonna be a
break between venom and spider-man in
this movie yet I believe that might come
in and either a spider-man movie where
Eddie's goes crazy I think in this it'll
be a Eddie Brock the Peter Parker
teaming up to take down carnage and to
expose the lie foundation for both
selfish and altruistic reasons so
complex like any good superhero movie
and to be clear why does jenna jameson
want to take it down because his son
John was killed by the Life Foundation
this is a vengeance for him yeah revenge
for his son I don't know if that's a
good enough motivator for me when my son
dies I know probably just go for a long
walk walk to remember with be afraid
Mandy all right one of us won't be
remembering anything I like that I like
that there's a little bit less going on
honestly and this only because I in
Eric's it you know it was almost hard to
get carnage in there cuz spider-man
could easily lead that movie
and in this one I would say at least you
know you can kind of see that I you know
carnage can be the main threat still so
I'm feeling it and I'm just gonna give
you you know I'm just feeling I'm gonna
give you three roadies three roadies
Ghostbuster story the other one is this
talking tow mater flashlight thing look
out ladies mater's fittin to get funky
[Laughter]
Wegmans brand hazelnut spread which we
all know is just Nutella but it's called
hazelnut n' and God knows when Hazel's
nut it gets everywhere Wegmans was the
Ghostbusters one correlated to he's got
a sloppy tongue looks like he could
really take some videos I think we
purposely trained right gotcha all right
uh Sam I'm going to be very curious to
see what role Spiderman plays in yours
because very prominent cameo in these
two theories okay so and I thank you for
I would try to stay silent cuz I wanted
to save the best for last I really like
to land the plane with this one I think
to kick it off we want to pick up with
Eddie after the events of interviewing
carnage and he is now let's let's throw
away a bunch of the alien stuff for now
let's not focus on that let's really
focus on him being an investigative
journalist that's what the kids go into
these movies to see they don't want to
see him turn no thanks no so we're
having him focus more on him being an
investigative journalist and he is
assigned by his editors to investigate
Peter Parker but deep down Eddie has a
feeling that something about this video
is fishy
it looks like fake news now we're
getting political this is what kids want
to see and there's
per hero movies more power logs
bugs bugs and so he he's able to hunt
down Peter Parker and he's able to
interview him and while this is going on
we have the inner monologue of venom
talking with Eddy and venom who has now
been asked by Eddy to stop eatin people
we're gonna do things that help people
is on a hero kick and after seeing what
spider-man's capable of and the kind of
hope he's able to instill in the people
of New York and a people of the world he
wants to be more like him which leads to
taking a little thing from Eric him
leaving Eddy and attaching himself to
Peter so that he can learn to be a
stronger hero but of course everything
goes wrong with some of my favorite
stories and spider-man comics is when
venom like knocks out Peter and he uses
his body as kind of like a tool to go
out and fight crime but he just stays
silent the whole time that way we get
the Spider Man costume I want the big
spider on venom even though it doesn't
really make a lot of sense I don't care
I want to see that I want to see that on
the costume I want to see in this story
Peter and Eddie having an argument about
what it means to be a hero and also what
they mean to the world as these enhanced
individuals and it could get to the
point where we help Peter get out of
this snag but I think we want to save
that for spider-man 3 because then what
was the point of the tease why would you
do that and throughout this Eddie knows
that there's something more to do with
carnage and his editor just keeps saying
no you have to talk to that Peter kid
you got to talk to that parker kid you
got to figure out if he's actually
spider-man or if J jonah Jameson is just
crazy in the while that's happening
carnage is sneaking out of prison so as
Peter and Eddie are coming to a head and
they're fighting over the Venom symbiote
and each other we see carnage get out
and he starts murdering people they got
a team up and they got to go after them
and that's how we get the maximum
carnage storyline on the big screen
where the kids have one is since the 90s
but no symbiotes in any of that oh no no
it's all swirling about it yeah Sam I
love it
that's three roadies oh it's coming
through
it's sorry my printer just got a little
kicked over here there we go oh my
goodness this is very creative of you
it's an Iron Giant
Tiki mug from the mondo tees and I'm
gonna count this it's the stir for it
Wow and yeah and also low on things a
three step foot peeling mask I think oh
that's the thing I've done that and sure
let's say that I already did one and
it's gross this okra is grosser than you
think is gonna be okay thank you though
Sam real quick before before we go into
tweets you don't know this but the whole
time you really actually had me extra
hooked because this small thing I it was
this idea that they keep debating about
what it's gonna what it is to be a hero
and then this idea that the thing that
makes Eddie Brock special the symbiote
has left him and has gone to someone
else one probably making a billion
unworthy of the symbiote but two it's
giving him a prime example of an
alternate way that the symbiote could
play out so he himself is probably
thinking like look man I'm covered in
symbiote goo
this is the best anybody can do with it
and then spider-man gets it and it's
just like a normal like heroic guy
obviously we know it like it's messing
with him too
but it shows Eddie that he maybe isn't
even good enough to like it shouldn't
have chose him he is gonna need to go on
an emotional arc to feel worthy of the
symbiote and of being a hero and for
that Sam you got a fourth row oh well
thank you so much this is the well now I
think you just know a TV show I like
it's a kuchi kopi squishy thing from
Bob's Burgers that sound a little
symbiote comes out of it
give me your theory again in the form of
a tweet but that is being written by
venom Oh so symbiote boys tweets
okay so this suite is being written by
venom he just tweeted Tom Holland just
canceled party and then you're like what
is this hashtag referring to and you
have to click around click around click
around and eventually you find the
original source tweet that was deleted
but screen grabbed and it's a picture a
selfie of Tom Holland posing with a
homeless person it was just a caption
beast and it means yes okay Jay jonah
Jameson says losing son is not fun
needs to send spider-man to help his
hand to investigate his son who was
alive but now late because he is dead
and he brockless carnage on his head
carnage he's a symbiote and Eddie Brock
can be an idiot until he gets his drone
back Tommy venom poetry is the thing I
didn't know I needed and I definitely
don't want great job I saying what he
got Oh easy uh venom if even if he has a
phone on him he's not gonna be using his
fingers he's gonna be using his long
gross tongue so it's gonna be all caps
removal it's just gonna be random
letters but to cap it off it's gonna be
a heart red heart and then the spider
emoji because he's looking to a little
fret find that spider-man and and team
up with them
easy-peasy remember when these tweets
help people remember what your theories
work now they ask the questions bare
mental are they forced us to investigate
more into what the hell they're afraid
I'm trying to be true to Kanan
yeah if you're trying to remember
just rewatch the first this episode I
can't award any more rookies for that
part uh so let's go ahead and give a
quick shout out thank you guys so much
to expressvpn so obviously many of us
are stuck at home right now and you
gotta be thinking about your internet
privacy Tommy I know you're staying with
family right now so that's probably
extra uncomfortable that's the only
reason I need to think about my internet
privacy no other reasons what a great
guy I am so sad is that Tommy doesn't
know about incognito mode either so
never I do everything on cam yeah this
stream was already going up in here so
uh but okay so all your online activity
can actually be traced your internet
service provider I just saw we got our
reports on Tommy they can actually know
every single website you visited that's
a hundred percent true so that's why
when we're at home we recommend using
expressvpn and just honestly don't go
online without it and make sure that
your ISP can't see whatever sites you
visited instead of reroutes your
internet connection through expressvpn
secure servers and they're a bunch of
the thousands of people that use those
and it's because there's so many people
on there and it's all anonymous nothing
can be traced back to you Tommy I'm
really pitching you hard on this yeah
I'm wondering do we get any sort of
employee discount on this thing because
I would love to find out more about this
after the show yeah we do have a
discount for all our employees that
watch this video everyone I which we'll
get to in one second just real quick
just so you know because I know you're
worried about this it doesn't crypt a
hundred percent of your data has
best-in-class encryption all your
information is protected and you can
just use your internet with confidence
on your computer tablet smartphone I
expressly PN works on every device that
you pretty much every device a you
connect to the internet with just tap a
button and then you're protected
expressvpn fastest most trusted VPN on
the market rated number one by C net I
love seeing it and wired
I love wired and those people obviously
know what they're talking about so
protect your online activity today with
the VPN that we trust to secure our
privacy you can visit our special link
Tommy
this is for you right here expressvpn
dot-com / rogue Tommy I know you spell
roguelike Rouge but it's our own gue and
but if you go there you get an extra
three months free on a one a package
so Tommy yeah your packages is increased
for free hold that thought
so expr ESS VPN comm / rogue expressvpn
comm / rogue to learn more speaking of
blue - guys are you having trouble
getting a nerection exam the story cool
trip a cool segue and yes no let's go
rogue what's in seconds head well you
think Sam has erectile dysfunction Mike
my dick just gave up popped off my body
and crawled into the garbage disposal
and then it got on me and I became guys
this is true I said this before that
blue Chu is a great way to find some
more confidence in the bedroom and I
said that I would try it myself uh so I
have it right here right there before we
started buddy here here's a 100% truth
I bought that because I said I would try
it and then it's send a free one I used
our art code I went to blue true calm I
got my first order free with using our
promo code new rock and ewr Ock it was
five bucks for shipping which is worth
it for five nights of shipping and it's
a blue2 calm and promo code new rock but
going back to it really quick
it really was crazy easy it's it's cheap
obviously the five bucks
to get it it's made in the USA it's the
same stuff that's in Viagra and Cialis
but you don't have to like I didn't have
to go to a doctor's office er and if
they were even like really interact to
the farmer say I just answered like two
questions and I drew a stick-figure well
more of like a limp figure I and then
the consultation was free and I got the
order shipped directly to my door and
discreet packaging but again I've said
it a million times it doesn't need to be
discreet I'm literally holding it up on
our YouTube channel in I don't care well
if you want that flag to stand tall blue
chu dot-com put the promo code new rock
and yeah I mean guys sure it sounds
pretty cool by the way this is my
favorite ad read of all time wait this
is an ad read what if I told you I've
used blue Chu every time you've seen me
for the last year and a half what if I
told you blue chew is the only thing
keeping me alive right yeah what if I
told you don't take that red pill take
the blue - what if I told you we got a
countdown going Oh oh my god my god
alright it's time to talk about all
right it's time to move on to our
discord rogue Theory the rest of
episodes gonna be very interesting guys
every week we play a rogue theory with
our patrons on discord this week there
were three patrons something's happening
Tony Camrys see I had really great
theories but our winner this week is
sinister super spy I so the question was
about what's what are the New Avengers
gonna be and what is the deal gonna be
what are they gonna be dealing with and
his answer I loved but we all voted on
this our judges in our audience and it
has Thunderbolt Ross becoming a greater
threat specifically using mutant growth
hormone to make his own kind of super
serum which results in lots of mutants
getting created but these are mutants
that are working for Thunderbolt Ross so
a new team of vendors has to form
featuring Falcon Sheree now and these
are just gets crazy new faces Namor echo
century team up to take them on guys
they take on mutants they create mutants
it's a whole new cast of Avengers what
do you guys think of the discord theory
oh I am uh I might I am throbbing with
excitement for this theory to see don't
Eric don't do now he'll penetrate the
Avengers like that
Chiron you know broke any windows in
your voice is my kink this theory was
engorged with details it's positively
ready to bust maybe I I just can't wait
to see a Thunderbolt Ross big and veiny
and red there you go there's the PP joke
I made the PP joke everyone happy I made
a peep I made a PP joke Sam you're above
that after you make use of it all right
all right next topic everyone so Star
Wars day may the fourth was yesterday
when we shot this so Disney made a big
announcement they've said Tycho a TV
director of thor ragnarok intro to
rabbit
among other great films he's going to be
directing a Star Wars film he's directed
an episode of Mandalorian he was the
voice of IG 11 we don't know any details
about this movie but here's why this is
a big deal remember
Disney and who knows who it was Kathleen
Kennedy whatever having the issues with
Lord and Miller when they tried their
take at solo Lord and Miller their trope
deconstruction style that is the lego
movie and that entire universe is not
too far away from Tycho a TV style now
Tegrity D has proved himself as being
able to kind of also have fun and hard
Jojo rabbit is an incredible film it's
dramatic
and hilarious at the same time maybe
they saw something there that they
didn't see in in the cut of so low that
they saw but they're giving him a shot
and remember this is the guy who
reinvented Thor so he's getting a Star
Wars movie someone here from you guys
what story or character in Star Wars is
Tyco a TD probably going to thor
ragnarok locked eyes I said [ __ ] dammit
uh and what's that story gonna be let's
go ro boom boom boom boom save the best
for first mango thank you very much
easy answer one letter three numbers no
two letters three nut two numbers two
letters C 3 p.m. let's see I want to see
tiger would he take on c-3po for a
number of reasons one as a dumb little
kid with a lot of nothing going on up
here I thought in the prequels that
c-3po was built by Anakin Skywalker and
that's not true depending if we're
looking on the legends or the new comics
or things filled in by other movies he
was he had a life before he was rebuilt
by Anakin Skywalker and there's a whole
story to be told about why he got his
red arm why has won silver leg what
happened between episode 6 and 7 and
what happened between 3 and 4 I want to
know what happened when his mind was
wiped before he went off with r2d2 and
got the message from Leia and it kicked
off the original series and I want to
know what led to the first order and how
he helped out Leia as a senator and as a
representative for the New Republic and
what happened I want to see it from his
point of view because he is a special
character in terms of what it means to
be a droid I know that in solo with with
L 337 that's how I read it I don't know
you can correct me on that one but we
saw that it was a more emotionally
driven droid who had who had a very
specific goal of liberating droids and
then there were like ha nice try you're
gonna be plugged into a ship forever
that's what your lives gonna be but he
gets true independence and we get we
could explore what that means
like when I dive into the background for
why he has a red arm that's
emotional reason for him having that
it's not because of a repair it is
because it the someone another droid
sacrifice sacrificed itself for him and
I want to know what that means
through his Eisen like you said with
Jojo rabbit and hunt for the wildering
rock you are able to take these stories
and have a perfect balance between heart
and drama and comedy and there's an
innate humor when it comes to c-3po
because he's so proper he's so British
uni so awkward in these situations
pairing them up with someone else
someone who probably has some sort of
New Zealand accent and having them go
across the galaxy together I think would
be a really good combo for a solo Star
Wars movie and we know that at least
ours has some Star Wars the company has
some confidence with Tycho TV after
seeing what he's able to do in the
Mandalorian season one hopefully he
comes back for season 2 as well I would
like to see him direct again but I think
they have confidence in him what they're
able to do with his what he's able to do
with their IP and I want to see that
story of c-3po such a pivotal character
in Star Wars Canon and what it's been
like for him through his eyes or photo
reflectors receptive whatever you call
them I burped a little bit at the end
sorry my point I think he I would rather
it focus on c-3po but I think it would
not be a bad idea of seeing Tyco with
TVs humour chops being shown through
that relationship and seeing how they
bounce off of each other and maybe
they're hunted down through throughout
the galaxy or what-have-you but I really
want to focus on c-3po specifically and
maybe by the end were able to see how
the relationship grows and changes and
is challenged I love that especially if
it is just these two droids and talking
about heart and whatnot in that I mean
remember not not only you know did those
characters already have a lot of heart
and we've seen that with bb-8 and with
r2 and whatnot but I mean look at wall-e
right so this is the same company in
that in the background there with Disney
wall-e is a movie words just this freaky
little robot guy and he doesn't even
speak real words and yet you know your
your weeping the moment that you know he
shows up on screen
so obviously droids can be the son of a
movie I love that idea I do see the
comedy I think is it Stephen Merchant
and um in Joe Joe rabbit yes as the SS
officer or whatever it is that energy of
like to proper but also like just like
leaning into that and being very I could
see that being very funny repeating
themself a lot all right and here's a
pitch for you Sam tell me if you like it
West world style you you said so many
things you wanted to see but to a
computerized brain all of time is
happening concurrently because it can
access any memory file at any given time
so we could be doing just a multi
timeline movie where we're seeing you
know his his birth
you know his death and maybe the arms
story various other stories and we're
kind of just seeing them almost unstuck
in time I wouldn't really be down for
that I'd really better be super down for
that and seeing ty could take on a more
sci-fi approach when it came to Thor
Ragnarok I think he could really balance
that well and his whole team already
looks impressive so I i hi I would be
very interested in seeing him tackle a
story like that well you got me excited
here's two rogue E's per se oh there you
go oh wow definitely didn't run out of
Rogi props I definitely have something
really good black hair dye out of a can
definitely wasn't from a Harry Potter
costume contest you use it use it you
know I shall actually that's gonna be
during my wish I'll put it there because
I'm think I'm gonna get it oh and it's
Matt Fraction and chips or duskies just
the tips book is it's it's a guide from
the writers of sex criminals over at
Image Comics it's a good funny book good
idea for a Rogi thank you so much if
you're looking down by the way and
you're only seeing just the tip blue
to.com remember I use promo code new
rock and you'll see a lot more than the
tip who's next
I'll go it's my turn now
I believe we have been leading up to
what this movie is going to be about
since force awakens we have started to
notice that in the more modern Star Wars
movies the stormtroopers have bigger
personalities they're not as they're not
meant to be seen as you know clones or I
know they're not close anymore but
they're not meant to be seen if these
like you know all bland boilerplate
people who all speak the same same
cadence same point of view they actually
start to have opinions and weakness like
like overt weaknesses cowardice or
bravery or whatever so I believe after
you know you see in the most recent
Disney Plus when they put out rise to
the skywalker there's a scene where the
stormtroopers are commenting on how
ghoulish the knights of ren are so like
even for them there's a bridge too far
and then of course the Mandalorian
episode with jason sudeikis as a
stormtrooper so I think this is going to
be a stormtrooper tale told through a
comedic lens and what I believe is
you're gonna have a grizzled
stormtrooper who's like the older been
around for a long time since the
beginning of the empire and he's he's
he's straight by-the-book straight
shooter and he's gonna be paired up with
a younger more wild card maybe a couple
maybe a group of younger stormtroopers
in experience and they're gonna get sent
on a mission that they just cannot
stomach maybe it's killing uncle Owen
and aunt Beru maybe it's something like
that maybe we tie it directly into the
Skywalker saga but it's give me
something that's just a bridge too far
for them so what's gonna happen is then
they go on the run from the Empire and
they basically it's a chase movie set in
the Outer Rim of these this ragtag group
of rebel troopers who eventually joined
the rebellion at the end of the movie
how many uh minimum of two maximum of
five I would say you could cast you know
like give me like a Liam Neeson and Liam
Neeson because he's going on June but
like give me uh give me a Jason Statham
and the kids from stranger things
and in a minivan just blasted across the
Spaceballs with he's driving yeah
Tommy I love it I think you you were
giving me like obviously thins story but
told as a comedy with like Thelma and
Louise vibes or something that's very
fun what's the the tightness of it how
do you get a little bit of a TD on it I
think that there's gonna be a lot of
physical comedy you know there's gonna
be a lot of what we expect to be taking
these stormtroopers this uniform precise
unit and showing like an arm plate
falling off showing a blaster misfiring
I mean like really hammering home they
have no aim they're terrible at aiming
maybe we see them training at a shooting
range or something in the beginning and
we see all the kids are just terrible at
it or maybe the instructor is drunk and
he never features them a proper
marksmanship and that's why maybe this
maybe that's a real blind spot for the
umpire actually worried about the
blasters they're there they're aiming
instructor is drunk so they forever
mimic he could be playing almost like a
grand moff tarkin type character that is
like complaining about the bureaucracy
of the empire and you know that's headed
all the way down like he can be kind of
doing the comment here or how
disorganized this supposedly
well-put-together Empire actually is
great I love it
Tommy that's a big fat too big Oh
engorged roadies no way and the first
one came in as the most basic white guy
action figure I've ever seen in my life
there's another this Ghostbusters toy
that is really fun you push down on it
and it snaps on your finger the out
why does the toy hurt you if you blast
the blue chair you can slap that lacquer
right down there won't go down okay so
the way that Taika Waititi gave us some
redemption for one of the less beloved
Marvel heroes Thor in the MC we loved
him but his movies first movies weren't
that good the third one really was the
the first good Thor movie I think you
gotta ask yourself who is the Star Wars
character in most need of redemption I
would argue mister Jar Jar Binks
senator George our Binks I should say I
think Tyga is gonna give us our good Jar
Jar movie in the Star Wars universe okay
so he already has the plot laid out
perfectly so imagine this is right after
the the Senate has collapsed and now the
Empire has risen
you have a young Gungan junior officer
in course sont who idolizes the Empire
he thinks it's a great thing he's
perhaps the nephew of senator Binks and
he idolizes his his uncle the senator
who helped Palpatine who gave him the
war power is necessary and he loves the
embargo thinks it's a great thing and he
wants to be a great imperial officer
he's in this training program but he
discovers a an escapee padawan who is
hiding in his quarters and through that
relationship he learns that the Jedi
aren't this evil thing that he's been
brainwashed into thinking and he working
with this this patawad this Jedi
youngling learns to maybe they work
together to score a victory for the
rebellion in stage and act of terrorism
against the Empire it's and maybe he
maybe the whole time Tyco plays a
version an imaginary friend version of
Jar Jar Binks
who
and it's basically Jojo Binks we'll just
call this Jojo banks working title I
love the idea of Jar Jar being like
redeemed but just the same way that Thor
was I think that's such a clever idea
Eric and then you just refer to rabbit
so you get one rogue yeah peridot it was
so good though yeah of course make it 10
times and it comes out as a double-a
battery whoa
would you just pull that out of I put a
dark place is that your mic yes great
all right give them all back to me in
the form of tweets that remind us of the
theory that you just gave mmm a movie
about stormtroopers that sounds super
tyka sends this ragtag group on the run
racing around the twin sons now this
tweet is done it's a comedy god I forgot
that you have to end your tweet so this
tweet is done Oh easy peasy
c-3po more like see me Pio take a golden
heart emoji red heart robotic arm and
that's it end of the tweed funny I'm on
board
oh yeah you're gonna go see it pissed
off mine is just a slow-motion video of
Jar Jar running with a younger Gungan as
the music plays your second be hero sigh
just a for once a day
give me back your okay all right thank
you all right all right guys it's time
for road questions getting very warm it
really it feels like I'm all blood now
guys uh number one Sony is trying to get
people to use SP um see the Sony
Pictures universe of Marvel characters
instead of spider-verse or Sony verse
how do you pronounce SP UMC and what
alternate definition would that word
have that's easy that's it I got easy
answer
keep the hippie hand on my head easy
anybody want to go Skaar OTC ROTC this
is pronounced spume c as in sperm see
these movies goddamn it we put it all on
the line here we've risked it all this
movie yeah that's interesting cuz my
thought was because I don't know if you
guys knew this but even though Sony has
a little bit more freedom with making
their movies there's a few things that
Marvel Studios and Disney have their
their claws sunken into and that is
specifically the sound effects whip and
so this is the new sound effect it's
Punk and that's the sound it makes when
it comes out of his web-shooters and
sticks to the wall and goes we didn't
stir it up a lot so it comes out a
little it comes out a little thicker
part water I think it's it's spoon see
and it's the ghost of Banksy who was
killed and into the spider verse but
he's mad that they used his name to
describe the the weird interdimensional
pixelization so he's haunting all these
characters
as a ghost I don't know why I'm giving
the void that's the Eric Oh the battery
is back and the batteries included
what's the battery no the battery still
is not you got it oh me something else
okay it is a different battery nice all
right guys I'm number two Nicolas Cage
has been cast as Joe exotic in an
upcoming Tiger King movie give us your
favorite Nicolas Cage movie quote in the
voice of Joe eggs exotic I'm really
quickly remembering how many times
off-screen producer Zack has submitted
things where you have to do a joke SATA
compressions I'm gonna give you an
alternate you can either do a Nicolas
Cage movie quote in a Joe exotic voice
or you can do a Joe exotic quote in a
Nicolas Cage oh I'm gonna go just rip
the band-aid off here if I mix I'm not
really good at impressions or singing or
acting is good bankrupt me financially
somebody else somebody else indication
in a mirror in a patient so I just
imagined Joe exotic exploring an island
with a cult and then eventually it's
it's run by Tigers who torture him and
put him in a flaming wicker tiger but
they torture him with bees
not those bees
I love it uh eric gets a roadie for a
commitment not a battery [ __ ]
it's a iPhone 8 case some way there's a
naked iPhone 8 alright so guys let's get
some point totals I did not keep track I
got my Sony headphones I got my cough
drop
I got pandemic I got a battery and I got
a knife okay so five bogeys thanks I
also have five because for some reason
my dueling impressions received nothing
I was just distracted by the the babies
also my blood not here man and I got six
I've got the hairspray I've got the book
I got the Tiki and the stirrer
I've got jeepers what did I where I put
all this stuff the foot and I got all
those jeepers and in the kuchi kopi oh
[Music]
this is well thank you my wish is if you
guys are familiar with the hit us
adaptation the office they have the
dundies awards and they're all pointless
Awards I would like if you guys could
give me an award each it could be for
like best at bowling best dress shoes
cool curly hair that they're testing out
with a new hair mask and they don't know
if they like it yet anything like that
and I'll write them down and all and
I'll keep them Sam you get the Dungey
for most unsettling ASMR lip spit sounds
that you're able to make close into a
mic
happy to present you with the always
there in a Grinch award for guy most
frequently bear to remind you that
Christmas is not actually a Christian
holiday but based on pagan celebrations
from years before Christ even existed
it's more about the great about Sam's I
will happily obsess except Sam will give
you the the Dundee for a guy who who
looks like you know he's 100% here for
the porn shoot but he wants to really
quick try falling in love before we
start rolling from a code new rock I
thank you so much to our great guest
this week Eric Voss as usual Tommy
Bechtel and stamp basher our winner
thank you love you all I'm very
attracted to each of you right now
I wonder why Phil Molina you know what
go see my thirst traps on Instagram at
Philippi this is why I do them
[Music]